- There's nothing more annoying than
a baby crying on a plane.
- Car honking is just so obnoxious.
- Most annoying noise in the
world is my mother's voice.
(imitates car honking sound)
- Any sound that wakes me
up is an unpleasant sound.
- The squeaky noise when you
have friction on balloons.
- The original Nokia ringtone.
- When someone is handling styrofoam.
(imitates squeaking styrofoam)
(imitates squeaking surfaces)
(imitates ringtone)
- As a kid, I used to be scared
of the THX sound in movies.
(imitates deep bass sound)
And you're just like, why is no one
else freaking out right now?
- What would be number one?
I wanna say babies crying because I feel
like that's pretty universal.
- I think it's just going
to sound like a really bad
Nine Inch Nails song, like
an unreleased deep track.
(electric drill sound)
(baby crying sound)
(bike brakes sound)
(grinder sound)
(female screaming)
(sound of nails on blackboard)
(sound of ruler on bottle)
(sound of chalk on blackboard)
(sound of fork on glass)
(suspenseful music)
(sound of disgust)
(sound of knife on bottle)
- It's definitely one of the worst,
but it also kinda sounds
like a rusty swing set.
- That just sucked.
That just really, really sucked.
- Fine tuned to worm
its way into your brain.
- I could take that, but like baby crying
for an hour I couldn't take.
- I still think the THX noise is scarier.
- Styrofoam is worse for me.
- To the person who decided
to record this noise,
(bleep) you.
- [Voiceover] My mom's voice is like
a cat that won't stop scratching.
(imitates scratching sound)
When are you going to get married?
I want grandchildren.
Why do you spend so much
money on Cheesecake Factory?